at some point you have to start asking
whether it's incompetence or malice with
the Andrew yang stuff CNBC during a
segment on the program squawk box about
the 2020 Democratic presidential primary
put up pictures of some other Asian guy
whose last name also happens to be yang
instead of a picture of the actual
candidate Andrew yang they also put up a
picture of a blonde senator Kirsten
Gillibrand instead of the actual
presidential candidate Tulsi Gabbard
whose hair is very very far from blonde
hard to imagine how the mistake was made
let's first take a look at the video
introduced by CNBC's Joe Koerner Kernan
who has previously attacked me on
Twitter as a communist or socialist or
something afterwards I will describe
what we see in the video the pictures in
question during this short clip are on
the right of your screen if you are
listening and not watching I will
describe it to you momentarily 2020
candidates have announced a
fourth-quarter fundraising hauls for
2019 president Trump's in the lead with
Sanders coming up second several
candidates announcing their best hauls
of the campaign cycle join us now for a
look at the impact the latest numbers
have on the 2020 race okay so now let's
look at it still still image as you can
see above yang it is a picture of an
Asian male whose last name is yang but
it is not Andrew yang the presidential
candidate it is reportedly Jeff yang the
founder of a company called redpoint
ventures then above Tulsi gabbard's name
it's a picture of New York senator
Kirsten Gillibrand now Gillibrand did
actually run for the Democratic
nomination this cycle I almost forgot
about that it feels like it was years
ago but it was this cycle she dropped
out Jeff yang to my knowledge was never
a candidate for the Democratic
nomination you might also remember that
MSNBC previously named Andrew yang John
yang in a lower third that said John
yang crowd surfs on 20/20 trail so I
want to hear from you is this
incompetence or is it malice I've
previously mentioned on the show
Hanlan's razor hanlin's razor is a quote
attributed to Robert J Hanlon of
Scranton Pennsylvania Scranton
a center of philosophy and proverbs for
sure hanlin's raiser says never
attribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity I
would actually start to think that this
is malice other than like what the hell
is the point I mean I hate to break it
to the yang gangers and the Tulsi people
I had both of them yesterday on Twitter
telling me that yang will be the
president of the united states that
Tulsi will be President neither is going
to even be the nominee I don't know like
why CNBC needs to do this to keep them
down so I'm leaning towards incompetence
of some kind but I do want to hear from
you I I think really if you say is that
malice or incompetence I think its
indifference to yang specifically more
so than to Tulsi CNBC has since
apologized producers say it was merely
an accident
squawk Ali host John fort explained
quote now unfortunately on this network
we accidentally aired the wrong photos
for both Andrew Yang and Tulsi Gabbard
and we apologize for that mistake so let
me know what you think what is the most
likely scenario here and by the way
speaking of because we have a story here
about Andrew yang and Tulsi I want to
point your attention to a Twitter post
that I made yesterday I yesterday I went
to my Twitter followers all hundred and
one thousand of you and I said I want to
hear from people i'm deepak min on
twitter i said i want to hear from
people who believed that andrew yang or
Tulsi will ultimately be the nominees
okay what is their path what states do
they win how do the numbers add up
whether or not you have an opinion on
that
check out the replies to that post this
was yesterday a January 7th that I
posted this on Twitter at D Pakman look
through the responses and see what you
think about the arguments being made by
the yang gangers and the the the tool
sees the Tulsa I don't know what the
column the Tulsi followers see if the
arguments resonate with you but also if
you are someone in that camp if you
believe that Andrew yang is going to be
the nominee if you believe that Tulsi
Gabbard is going to be the nominee find
my
post on Twitter from yesterday about
this and respond to me and tell me what
their path is I am interested in I I may
even do an upcoming segment saying here
is how the yang Kang ORS and the tool
sees see their respective candidates
having a path to the nomination I think
it could be interesting insight into
their minds and their thought process